[Music]
wake up the members of my nation
icarly officially has a release date on
friday the og
cast miranda cosgrove jerry traynor and
nathan kress were with the newbies
lacey mosely and jaden triplett to
celebrate miranda's
28th birthday on set happy birthday
[Music]
and inside her sprinkled covered
explosion cake was the big surprise
announcement
hi carly premieres june 17th
lacey also took to instagram to honor
miranda on her special day writing
i've never found a new friend on a job
so quickly miranda you're a hilarious
talented beautiful and kind individual
the beloved nickelodeon show premiered
in 2007
and ran for six seasons before it ended
in 2012.
the show followed miranda's character
carly shea as her internet show icarly
became a success
okay for our first real-life harley
cooking segment we're gonna make
spaghetti taco jerry played carly's
brother spencer while nathan played her
best friend freddie
the three of us got back together and
was like just riding a bike he was like
we're back e.t caught up with a trio at
this year's kids choice awards where
they ditched new secrets about the
upcoming paramount revival series
it feels kind of crazy we did the first
table read about a week or so ago and it
was
kind of insane like just getting
everybody back together again and
it was really fun did you find were you
like was it easy for you
i kind of thought it was yeah yeah yeah
we shot a promo a little while ago and
it was like the three of us got back
together and it was like
just riding a bike it was like we're
back oh yeah and the cool part is what
makes it different too is we have new
characters that are coming as well so it
is
a lot of the familiar you know it's a
lot of familiar faces but there's new
people involved that are going to change
up the story a ton and make it
very interesting uh and i think somewhat
unexpected
that's right lacey is playing carly's
best friend harper
somewhat replacing jeanette mccurdy who
played sam on the og
show but has since quit acting while
jaden will be playing freddie's
stepdaughter
i have a kid now so that's you know that
changes
the dynamic a little bit uh instead of a
show
yes he is a kid right also don't you in
real life also in real life
yes he also has a kid yeah in like two
weeks you're gonna have yeah
in two weeks i'll have two kids yeah so
just kids everywhere
i have no kids thank goodness
miranda no kids in the show
no kids
[Laughter]
that we know that's right and in the
series finale carly and freddie shared
a major goodbye kiss so does this mean
their relationship is over in the
revival
tbds i don't know
i have no idea and even if i didn't know
i wouldn't tell you
we gotta we gotta keep things spicy for
the folks at home can't say it right
miranda too
juicy too juicy to say see i feel like
there's a lot of
secrets yeah we don't know when we're
gonna get in trouble for uh
saying too much i'll say the scripts are
really funny mm-hmm
anybody's expecting what we're doing
what we're doing
i just don't think it's i don't think a
revival has been done quite
this way
you